We’re ready?
Putin's intervention in Syria, which was extremely
effective with very minimal damage to Russia's
treasury or blood expansion—casualties—has
shown the West that when the West creates
vacuum, when the West retreats from the self-imposed
red lines, again and again, Russia will exploit
it and Russia will re-establish itself in
the areas where the former Soviet Union used
to be very influential.
This is what I call the Putin doctrine.
In fact, even in the official announcement,
it is clear that he's going to leave behind
up to 800 soldiers, quite a few jet fighters
and jet bombers and special designation troops,
the so called Spetsnaz.
There is no permanent withdrawal at all.
When the U.S. withdraws, everything is emptied,
all the bases are gone, all the soldiers are
gone.
The lesson and the takeaway is that do not
leave a policy vacuum, a geostrategic vacuum,
Russia will always jump in.
So do you think Putin has withdrawn from Syria?
Let us know in the comment section what you
think, and please let us know if there’s
anything else you want us to cover in 60 seconds.